So, so far all the computation we've done
is operated only on numbers, and in the
early days of computing, people thought of computers
as super powerful calculators, for doing computations like
simulating nuclear weapons, computing ballistic tables, or breaking
encryptions, which was a little more than just
arithmetic. But still was mostly about counting and
doing simple arithmetic. We saw this quote from
Grace Hopper earlier talking about computers could only do arithmetic, and
this is what people thought about computers in the 1940s and
1950s. But there's no reason to limit computers to that. They
can operate on any kind of data we want, and it
gets much more interesting when we operate on data besides just
numbers. If we're going to build a search engine, most of the
data that we want to deal with is not numbers. It's
the letters that are contained in webpages, and in Python, that's what
we call a string. A string is just a sequence of
characters surrounded by quotes. So here's an example of a string
in Python, it starts with a single quote, has a sequence
of characters and anything that we can type on the keyboard can
be in a string, and ends with another single quote. The
string is the sequence of characters between the single quotes. If
we want, we can use double quotes instead. If we use
double quote, then the double quote starts the string. We can have
a sequence of characters and a double quote that ends the
string. The only requirement is that if we start the string
with a single quote, it has to end with a single
quote. If we start the string with a double quote, it
has to end with a double quote. And that's actually a
handy property. Because that means we can have the other kind
of quote within our string. This string starts with a double
quote. It contains a single quote inside it. But because we started
with a double quote, that single quote doesn't end the string.
That single quote is just like another character in the string.
The string continues. Until the closing double quote. So let's try
some things in the Python interpreter. So, we can print a
string, just like we can print a number. So here I'm
printing the string hello. And when we run this, we see
the output hello. It's printing hello. We don't see the single
quotes as it prints, but we know that it's a string that
was printed. We can print a string with double quotes,
and one thing to notice when you enter strings through the
interpreter, the color is black now, since it's an open
string, it hasn't been finished, once I type the final quote,
that closes the string, the color changes to blue. So
now when we run this, we have two prints, both that
print hello, it looks the same both times. It doesn't matter
if we use single quotes or double quotes around our string.
Just to check everyone's paying attention, I'm going to try one
more thing. And now I am printing hello without the quotes.
You can guess what that will do. We won't make a
quiz of this, but try to guess before I run it.
Now that I run this, we see the result.
We get a name error. The name Hello is not
defined. Without the quotes, this looks just like a variable.
It's a name, but it's a variable that we didn't
define. So when I try to use it, I get
an error that the variable name Hello is not defined.
If I wanted to I could define a variable named
hello. Let's make hello refer to the string howdy and
now when I print hello, it works. I see the first
two prints that printed hello, now when I print the variable hello,
well that refers to the string howdy and I see howdy as
the result. We usually don't want our variables to start with capital
letters. That's just a convention, so I'm going to change this
back to a lower case hello because it makes me feel uncomfortable
to have a variable with a capital letter. There's no rule against
that in Python. It's just a convention that we like to follow.